dr kim is a researcher working on a
project to create a warhead for north
and south korean joint forces in the
opening scene she watches news on
television that talks about a massive
comet passing dangerously close to earth
it returns to the earth every 433 years
but this time it will be visible because
of the distance in the meantime the
military leaders of north and south
korea are discussing their plan to
surrender a nuclear warhead it was being
built in a secret bunker with the joint
efforts of both countries under dr kim
however after constantly being pressured
by other world leaders they have to
reluctantly give up the warhead which
will be transported to another country
in the morning the initiative is
supposed to bring peace to the nations
but a north korean major named kang is
displeased with the consolation hence he
along with north korean soldiers kidnaps
dr kim who has a key card to the unit
where the nuke is kept by midnight the
nuke is stolen and brought to the waters
even dr kim ends up being kidnapped
amidst the chaos soon the south korean
soldiers find out about the intrusion a
platoon under the leadership of major
park is dispatched to catch kang and his
team of soldiers in the following scene
both parties meet each other in the
middle of the han river a loud bang is
heard that initiates a gunfight between
them however they fail to realize that
the noise came from a massive comet
passing dangerously close to the earth
the phenomenon causes the boat to
disappear the screen goes black and when
dr kim opens her eyes she finds herself
in a field several men in traditional
clothing are running about and fighting
it turns out that the comet caused a
time rift in the atmosphere sending
three north and three south korean
soldiers into the year 1572 alongside dr
kim who never wanted to be a part of
this currently the war between joseon
era koreans and jirchian invaders is
going on the soldiers think it is a joke
until someone tries to attack them in
retaliation they kill the chirchian
soldiers with an explosive angering
their commander the commander tries to
attack them but stops when a gunshot
hurts his ear after the invaders leave
the poor korean villagers surround the
soldiers and treat them as messiahs they
are given the nickname heavenly soldiers
due to their abilities that seem magical
to the villagers because the situation
is foreign to the soldiers they stay in
a cave for the night park points his gun
at kang blaming him for everything when
the conversation gets heated dr kim
calms both parties ordering them to put
the conflict aside until they figure out
how to get back to the future more
importantly she is worried about the
missing nuke that is a hundred times
more intense than the atomic bombs used
in world war ii it seems to have been
lost when they entered the time rift
since kang is responsible for its
disappearance he promises to find the
nuke one way or the other somewhere else
the jerchan leader is busy shaming the
commander who ran away from the
battlefield earlier even though the
commander argues that the soldiers were
extraordinary the leader doesn't excuse
his cowardice he hands the commander a
crossbow and gives him one last
opportunity to kill all of heaven's
soldiers back in the cave a commoner
spies on the soldiers and tries to steal
from them when they are asleep however
the guy is an idiot and decides to help
the soldiers sleep comfortably instead
of running away with the stolen items he
is eventually caught but the commotion
attracts the attention of the village's
guards as a result the thief and two
soldiers are taken to the king for
display of violence kang and park dress
up as commoners and watch the hearing
from the sidelines the thief's name is
announced to be ye sun sen from a place
called assan the name sounds familiar to
park and upon embarking on it he
realizes the thief is the legendary
korean warrior who will later become
instrumental in the defeat of the
japanese invasion yee is considered a
nation's hero and the greatest korean
warrior in modern days but seeing him in
real time the major is in disbelief
because he is nothing like how the
modern korean histories illustrate him
the king orders to be head ye and both
soldiers for stealing an explosive that
he thinks is a metal ball at night the
three of them are locked in prison until
a soldier comes to their rescue apart
from helping the soldiers he also forces
ye to come with them it turns out that
yi stole weapons from the cave earlier
and the soldiers want them back ye
argues he threw them into the river but
no one believes him park tells everyone
that yi is no other than the great
warrior they read about in history
classes the information leaves everyone
in shock as they turn to look at the
idiotic thief who doesn't possess a
single quality of a warrior yi manages
to run away when the others are
distracted however when he wakes up the
next morning the soldiers are in his
front yard making themselves at home
they bow down addressing him as the
general and asking for forgiveness he
believes they are trying to trick him
but cannot protest against all six of
them starting the next day park takes it
upon himself to train ye and make him
the general he is destined to become ye
is confused at first but eventually
comes to terms with the harsh training
meanwhile kang and the north korean
soldiers continue looking for the nuke
which they think has time traveled with
them they make maps and search every
part of the village but are unable to
find it one morning when no one is
around ye goes to the woods with the
weapons he had stolen from the soldiers
he believes they are worth a lot of
money and wants to sell them in the
future he buries them near a tree and a
little peasant girl sees him doing so
she is curious about the guns but ye
manages to send her away after bribing
her with a bar of chocolate however a
few hours later she walks out of the
woods with a gun in her hands the
jerchan spies sent to find the soldiers
notice the girl they register that the
soldiers must be nearby because of the
gun in the meantime park and the others
treat ye with respect and take great
care of him dr kim thinks they should
not try to interfere with yi's life
because it might change the future of
the entire nation but park believes ye
needs them to become a warrior one
afternoon dr kim excitedly gathers
everyone and reveals that she has
discovered something about the comet the
last time it traveled close to earth was
433 years ago which is why they were
transferred to 1572. it's exactly 433
years earlier than their time if they
follow the pattern according to the
moon's calendar the next comet will pass
in four days which means they can return
home the only problem is that she
doesn't know what part of the village
they should be in when the comet passes
but she is positive she will find a
solution to that at night park sees his
soldiers digging through yi's belongings
they find many plant roots and figure
out yi is actually a lowly smuggler they
burn all of it asking ye to get his act
together and do what he is supposed to
do for the nation angered by them
treating him like a kid ye storms away a
while later a south korean soldier finds
him and pretends to read his palm
telling him everything he will achieve
in the future he laughs at the guy
refusing to believe him when the soldier
tries to tell him the entire truth an
arrow lands in his neck and kills him ye
is then surrounded by the church and
invaders and abducted they hold him
hostage showering him with whips to
torture him the commander wants to know
where the rest of the soldiers are if he
tells them he gets to be killed
peacefully but if not he might suffer a
lifetime's worth of torture even when he
is shown the decapitated head of the
soldier he refuses to tell them anything
but then the commander brings the
peasant girl who had the gun to save the
little girl's life yi promises to show
them the soldier's residence in the
morning the commander lets the girl go
free but then hits her with an arrow
before she can run away he threatens to
do the same to yi if he doesn't hold up
his end of the deal that sounds better
than a lifetime's worth of torture at
night when everyone is asleep kang and
his coordinates come to yi's rescue they
also discover the nuclear warhead was
inside a tent all along and are finally
able to retrieve it amidst the mission
they enter a room where the heir of the
jerchan is resting he has the gun that
was stolen from the girl which he tries
using on kang however kang with his
amazing reflexes manages to kill the guy
and run away with ye the next morning
the cherchen leader finds his son's dead
body and is stricken with grief with a
renewed sense of revenge both the leader
and commander make it their mission to
kill the escapee somewhere else ye is
shaken by the unjust death of the child
he repeatedly hears his father and the
soldiers telling him to pass the
military test and become a general until
now he believed he was a loser who
couldn't achieve anything great in life
but after witnessing the girl's death he
gets a reason to fight meanwhile with
the nuke in their possession dr kim
notices the timer on it has moved from
ten to five minutes this means they have
been here for five days because one
minute of real time is equal to one day
of time in the past using the nuke the
timing and location of the comet's
passing are accurately calculated hence
the soldiers prepare to leave the past
as it currently stands in the following
scene they are holding a funeral for the
dead member of their team just then they
are approached by the villagers who have
dug out the weapons from the woods they
want the soldier's help to seek revenge
for the girl who was killed apparently
she was an orphan who was liked by
everyone in the village because she had
no parents the villagers all grieve her
death as though she was their own
daughter initially major park is
skeptical because he doesn't want to
interfere with the past however he
changes his mind when kang comes forward
and agrees to help the villagers
alongside the modern koreans prepare for
the battle while planning a strategy for
the attack kang and park get into an
argument that ends up in a fist fight
they only stop when ye orders them too
he makes them realize that their rivalry
is nothing compared to the villager's
safety park sees that yi has finally
gained his essence as a future general
for an entire day yi inspects the areas
around the village and figures out which
path their rivals are going to take he
even surprises everyone by planning a
clever tactic of attack after analyzing
all the aspects of the battle according
to him they can hide in the narrow part
of the hill where the rivals will be
coming from that way only 10 of them can
pass through at a time and they can kill
them easily still there is a huge chance
that all of them will die in the battle
since the villagers are going against
the trained fighters of jer chen on the
day before the arrival of the jercens dr
kim notices that their clocks are moving
faster this means the comet is
accelerating at a greater speed and they
will have to return home before the
churchens invade the soldiers have to
choose between returning to their old
life or helping the villagers they
decide to go with the former because
staying in the village might not help ye
in the long run as they prepare to leave
park suggests ye also run away to save
his life he has to be alive for the
future when the japanese invade korea
hence he cannot risk being killed in a
less important battle enraged by the
suggestion ye loses respect for park but
in the end he is knocked out and carried
off for his own good everything goes
according to plan until the north
koreans realize that they will be
sentenced to death when they return to
the future for stealing the nuclear
warhead at the last minute kang changes
his mind and elects to go back to the
village to help defend it from the
jercens the others follow his lead and
decide to stay behind for their own
reasons they even hand their necklaces
to dr kim asking her to return them to
their families a while later the
stubborn yee manages to escape his
confinement and joins the soldiers and
the villagers in their battle the
invaders initiate the first attack
giving rise to a long and hard fight the
soldiers use the guns and explosives to
kill the first batch of soldiers before
they do any damage but when the second
batch arrives with crossbows the
villagers are pushed back and most of
them are killed the leader of the
jerchans kills many soldiers and weakens
the team major kang also dies after
taking an arrow to save yee's life in
the end only sergeant choi and park are
left alive out of all of heaven's
soldiers after an intense battle the
leader of the rivals is finally killed
and the villagers become the victor
somewhere else dr kim is also attacked
by the jerchans a guard fights them to
keep her safe she is almost killed by a
grenade but the comet arrives right on
time and creates the time rift yet again
she and the warhead make it back to the
present and she reports their
experiences to the korean generals the
superiors don't believe the story of
time travel but now that they have the
nuke they do not care about the missing
soldiers at last they decide to turn
over the warhead and maintain peace in
both nations in the last scene we see dr
kim visit a local memorial of admiral
yee she misses the soldiers and ye and
is sad that she doesn't know what
happened to them the scene then shifts
to the time of the battle of myeong-yang
strait there we see that yi has now
become the general and is preparing to
face the japanese soldiers in the battle
he and only 13 korean ships successfully
destroy an over 300 strong japanese
armada aboard his flagship yi is with
none other than park and choi who are
now his staff officers subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching